to me it's a little bit also
heartbreaking
that
you know with google and facebook like
deepmind and so on so much of the talent
you know doesn't stay necessarily for
prolonged periods of time in these
in in these universities oh yeah i mean
the
some of the companies are more guilty
than others are paying
fabulous salaries to some of the highest
you know producers and then just
you never hear from them again they're
not allowed to give public talks they're
sort of locked away
and it's sort of like collecting
collecting you know hollywood stars or
something and i'm not allowed to make
movies anymore i own them um yeah that's
tragic because i mean the
there's an openness to the university
setting where you do research too uh
both in the base of ideas and space like
publication all those kinds of things
yeah you know and you know there's the
publication and all that and often you
know although these places say they
publish yeah there's pressure
and um
but i think for instance um you know
net-net i think
google buying those 809 robotics company
was bad for the field because it locked
those people away
they didn't have to make the company
succeed anymore lock them away for years
and then
sort of all fritted away yeah
so um
do you have hope for almighty
for mit yeah why shouldn't i
well i could be harsh and say that
i'm not sure i would say mit is leading
the world in ai
or even stanford
or berkeley i would say
i would say
deepmind google ai
facebook ai so i would take a slightly
different approach or a different answer
uh i'll leave i'll come back to facebook
in a minute but i think those other
places are
following a dream of
one of the founders
and i'm not sure that it's well founded
the dream
and i'm not sure that it's going to have
the impact
he believes it is
um
you talking about facebook and google
and so on i'm talking about google
google but the thing is those research
labs aren't
there's the big dream
and i'm i'm usually a fan of no matter
what the dream is a big dream is a
unifier because what happens is you have
a lot of bright minds
working together
uh on a dream what results is a lot of
like adjacent ideas i mean yeah so much
progress is made yeah i'm i'm so i'm not
saying they're actually leading i'm not
i'm not saying that the universities are
leading yeah but i don't think those
companies are leading in general because
they're
you know and we saw this
incredible spike in you know
attendees at europe's and
as i said in my january 1st review this
year for
2020
2020 will not be remembered as a
watershed year for machine learning or
ai
you know there was nothing
surprising happened anyway unlike when
deep learning hit imagenet
that was a that was a
shape
there's a lot more people writing papers
but the papers are fundamentally boring
yeah and uninteresting incremental work
you